ريال هكذا تتعالى اصوات البائعين في
تظاهره الموسميه تحتضنها محافظه رفحاء
بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
الكما او ما يعرف محليا بالفجع نبته
الموسميه خلقت حركه اقتصاديا في كل شتاء
اسعار الفقع قد لا يحدها سقف امام اقبال
كبير للظفر بها البوابه الاولى بالنسبه
للكماء منطقه الشمال الاسعار عندنا هنا
خلال مبيعات 15 يوم تقريبا تجاوزت المليون
و200,000 ريال السوق
بالنسبه للشريطيه المملكه كلها متواجدين
امس حقيقه تجاوز 360,000 ريال امس كان في
الطرب اكثر من العرض وجميع الاسواق هذه
الشغاله الان في المملكه كلها المصدر هناك
من يرى بان الكما لا يظهر مبكرا بهذا
الحجم وانما يحتاجه بعضا من الوقت ليصل
الى ذروته ولكن المختصين هناك في هذا
السوق الشعبي يرون عكس ذلك
وانا اكد على الجميع 100% بحيثكم حكم
خبرتي اكثر من 20 سنه الفقع محلي 100%
وانا مسؤول عن كلامي هذا فقع محلي
وما مزارع ما جائنا مزارع موجود ولا مزارع
اغلى من الفقع لجينا الميزان كيلو 1200
ريال احنا الكيلو عندنا 750 ريال
الفقعوا النادر من انواع الفطر يظهر في
الصحراء بعد سقوط الامطار ب70 يوما وله
انواع عده من اشهرها واغلىها ثمنا الزبيدي
ذو اللون الابيض والرائحه القويه ثم
الغلاسه الذي يتميز بلونه البني المائل
للاحمرار اما اقلها انتشارا فالجبا بلونه
البني الداكن من محافظه رفحاء جزاعا مصير
العربيه